the hills are alive with the sound of
mucus that's according to one actor in
the movie anyway plus why does james
bond make his actors so miserable sean
connery wanted to kill the character and
daniel craig felt even worse welcome
martini chicken was stirred i don't know
how to give her them kate winslet placed
herself firmly on hollywood's radar when
she made her debut in peter jackson's
oscar-nominated psychological thriller
heavenly creatures but it was her turn
as troubled socialite rose in james
cameron's titanic that made her a global
star the film won a record-tying 11
academy awards and opened up some big
doors for winslet though she also
admitted that she actively avoided big
movies later fearing she would quote
burn out by the age of 25 if she didn't
looking back on titanic 15 years later
winslet revealed that she hated her
performance and would love a do-over in
2012 she told the telegraph every single
scene i'm like really really you did it
like that oh my god even my american
accent i can't listen to it it's awful
hopefully it's so much better now
winslet continued it sounds terribly
self-indulgent but actors do tend to be
very self-critical i have a hard time
watching any of my performances but
watching titanic i was just like oh god
i want to do that again
harrison ford has always had a
complicated relationship with the star
wars franchise and his character han
solo who he once mockingly referred to
as ham yo-yo still he's been known to
change his tune periodically one star
wars actor whose negative opinion of his
character never faltered during his
lifetime with sir alec guinness who
hated the jedi master obi-wan kenobi
with a passion his authorized biography
contained some telling notes that
guinness exchanged with an associate
during the casting and filming process
guinness wrote novelist and friend
pierce paul reed to tell him he'd been
offered a role in a paul lucas film he
was apparently bad with names also
referring to harrison ford as tennyson
ford guinness biggest concern it seemed
was with the movie genre he wrote it's
science fiction which gives me pause
fairy tale rubbish but could be
interesting perhaps later correspondence
shows that he didn't find the experience
interesting far from it in fact guinness
wrote can't say i'm enjoying the film
new rubbish dialogue reaches me every
other day and watches a pink paper and
none of it makes my character clear or
even bearable
bond
james bond ever the charmer sean connery
once said i have always hated that
damned james bond i'd like to kill him
connery made his debut as the british
spy in 1962's dr no and would go on to
reprise the role on six occasions the
last movie of his original run as the
spy you only lived twice left him
thoroughly disgruntled connery already
felt as though he wasn't being paid
handsomely enough to make up for all the
amount of work and intense media
attention but when photographers
followed him into a public bathroom
while he was shooting on location in
japan he decided that he had enough
connery quit the role although he also
returned to it twice once for 1971's
diamonds are forever and again for
1983's never say never again which was
made independently of producer albert r
cubby broccoli the two had a bitter
dispute over salary and royalties and
connery didn't even attend broccoli's
funeral and associated the actor once
told the new york daily news sean still
feels aggrieved by how he was treated by
cubby over the years he felt that he was
never well financially rewarded for his
early work and after his departure his
work was used to generate tens of
millions of dollars
sean connery often tops polls ranking
the best bonds but there's no doubt as
to who's been the most successful in
terms of box office returns daniel
craig's outings as double of seven have
pulled in giant stacks of cash worldwide
and his name is now synonymous with the
character though his overall experience
with the franchise may have been less
than positive in 2015 when he was asked
if he'd be interested in returning for a
fifth outing craig didn't mince words
telling time out i'd rather break this
glass and slash my wrists i'm over it at
the moment we're done all i want to do
is move on craig explained that playing
bond had become a drag for him because
he was expected to be smooth and smart
at all times which became a distraction
for him on set he said the best acting
is when you're not concerned about the
surface bond is the opposite of that you
have to be bothered about how you're
looking it's a struggle still craig
admitted one thing could entice him back
to the role saying if i did another bond
movie it would only be for the money
craig's fifth bond movie no time to die
hit theaters in october 2021
the hearts of teenage girls everywhere
shattered collectively when news broke
that twilight star robert pattinson
couldn't actually stand playing edward
cullen the franchise's 108 year old
sparkly vampire once a cat was out of
the bag our pats didn't exactly let up
when it came to venting his frustrations
i hardly get to do any vampire stuff
i mean
uh yeah i don't get to kill anyone i
really want to kill some people with it
twilight author stephanie meyer told mtv
that she and pattinson disagreed about
how edward should be betrayed from the
moment they met and the actor would
later air his grievances publicly he
once told fans at an event in brussels
girls often say that edward's so perfect
but he's not i do not like people who
try to exert control in a relationship
when there is an imbalance this is very
wrong and very strange pattinson went on
to insist he was nothing like the overly
serious edward cullen in real life and
argued that his character's romance with
bella swan was the most awful
relationship in the world perhaps
unsurprisingly pattinson spent a great
deal of his time after the twilight saga
playing weirder more interesting roles
in lower budget movies
when julie andrews and christopher
plummer sat down with vanity fair to
celebrate the 50th anniversary of the
sound of music in 2015 the latter
actually had some pretty good things to
say about the film this marked a
pleasant change for the actor who once
referred to the classic musical as the
sound of mucus the actor was never
particularly complimentary about captain
von trapp the character that wound up
defining his movie career plummer did at
least pay respect to director robert
wise who he credited with keeping the
film from falling over the edge into a
sea of treacle speaking a few years
earlier during a star-studded roundtable
chat hosted by the hollywood reporter
plummer revealed that his role in the
sound of music was the most challenging
one he'd ever taken not because of the
singing scenes or the fact that he had
to work with a cast of children but
because it was all too cheesy to bear
miley cyrus still had enough love for
hannah montana to celebrate the disney
show's 10th anniversary on social media
in 2016 but she's made no secret of what
playing her most famous character cost
her she once told marie claire i was
told for so long what a girl is supposed
to be from being on that show i was made
to look like someone that i wasn't which
probably caused some body dysmorphia
because i had been made pretty every day
for so long and then when i wasn't on
that show it was like who the [ __ ] am i
playing hannah montana also cost cyrus
financially she revealed during an
interview with elle that the mouse house
took advantage of her with low wages
underpaying her in the full knowledge
that as the star of the show she
deserved a lot more she remembered i did
not grow up spoiled in any way i just
wanted to be on tv i mean at one point
they'll probably kill me for saying it i
was probably the least paid person on my
cast because i didn't know any better i
was just like i can be on disney yeah i
want to do it the controversial pop star
has since shot down any hopes of a
hannah montana reboot happening in the
foreseeable future
greece 2 didn't make anywhere near as
big of an impact as the original but for
actor maxwell caulfield who starred as
foreign exchange student michael it
never really went away after appearing
opposite of young michelle pfeiffer in
the sequel the british theatre actor's
promising career in the film business
suddenly went stagnant he later told the
yorkshire post i learnt a pretty harsh
lesson early on after greece two the
films i'd been promised never
materialized caufield went on to praise
phifer for taking a calculated risk with
her next role saying michelle was smart
right afterwards she did scarface with
al pacino that showed that she had range
that she was versatile me well i was
stuck for a while with a reputation as a
bubblegum actor times got so bad for
caulfield in the years that followed
that he almost quit acting on several
occasions at one point coming very close
to accepting a job at a car dealership
thankfully for him it never came to that
but making his breakthrough in such a
widely panned movie meant he'd always
struggled to be taken seriously as an
actor
one of the biggest criticisms that the
late marlon brando faced during his
lifetime was that he only knew how to
play variations on himself an accusation
he both denied and resented the
dedicated method actor first came to the
attention of casting directors while
playing stanley kowalski in a staged
production of a streetcar named desire
that ran for two years on broadway in
the late 1940s as receiving an offer he
couldn't refuse he made the transition
to moving pictures and reprised the role
of kowalski in the 1951 film adaptation
of streetcar there seemed to be a
misunderstanding of what method acting
actually was at the time and the public
blurred the line between brando's
performance as the volatile kowalski and
his real-life persona in a 2008 feature
on him the new yorker said brando hated
stanley and that he spoke of the
character with a sense of disgust in one
interview brando once said kowalski was
always right and never afraid he never
wondered he never doubted his ego was
very secure and he had the kind of
brutal aggressiveness that i hate i'm
afraid of it i detest the character
of all the actors who have reportedly
hated the character that made them
famous perhaps none were unhappier than
george reeves whose most well-known role
is said to have driven him to take his
own life the classically trained actor
made his credited feature film debut as
one of scarlett o'hara's suitors and the
1939 classic gone with the wind and from
there he appeared to have a bright
future in the industry when he was
offered the lead role in the 1952
adventures of superman tv series he
accepted but refused to play the hero's
alter ego clark kent as the bumbling
reporter of the comics insisting that
the show deal with more adult themes the
studio initially agreed but they soon
realized that their ideal target
audience was children and decided to
alter the show's content accordingly
much to reeves frustration according to
some reports he once raised a glass to
the actress playing lois lane at the
time and said here's to the bottom of
the barrel babe it would be the last
role reeves would ever play as he was
forever typecast as the man of steel in
1959 he was found on his bed with a
gunshot wound to the head
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]